hey youtubers is Charlie so some serious
berserker went down into the Teen
Wolf finale they did a really good job
of blowing things up in our faces while
teasing things out - season five there
is a whole lot to talk about so this is
just gonna be for the finale and then
I'll do a video for season 5 predictions
tomorrow be sure to subscribe to get
that if you're just finding me for the
first time if you guys are wondering
what to watch now that Teen Wolf was
gone for a while I'll make a few
recommendations at the end of the video
but careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet I'll
wait just a sec ok here we go here are
my top 10 WTF moments starting with
number 10 Berserker Scott tries to kill
Kira I'd like how they focused the
camera on his eyes whenever Kate was
explaining he had never killed anyone
even if he did kill someone now his eyes
would still glow alpha red like they're
not gonna glow blue the only time they
do shifts colors is when you're not an
alpha at least unless you're some other
kind of creature is anyone else just a
little bummed that Lydia's eyes don't
glow I really wanted a deeper dive into
the mechanics of berserkers and how that
magic worked but the probably just add
that to a DVD commentary if they do one
or one of you guys could totally ask
Jeff Davis at the next convention but
number 9 Derrick gives Liam the talisman
what three things cannot stay hidden I
love that team's steric moment they
shared whenever Derrick was trying to
help Liam it was fun to see him flip out
during the full moon but I really wanted
to see him Hulk out during that final
big battle I guess that's just something
they're saving for season 5 otherwise
they totally would have done it already
Liam literally took a back seat in the
finale and have they got enough for bead
this year like they got three B last
year I feel like that's when he really
would have started to stand out but
speaking of standing out number eight
Lydia with the baseball bat I really
hope she joins the softball team next
year that would just be so much fun
there's no way that's gonna happen
but there was this really funny
flashback that I had while I was
watching there was this moment a long
time ago where Liddy and stiles are at
the lacrosse field and he had a baseball
bat and she turns to him and says we
need to find someone who's better with a
bat cut to now where she is that better
person I think it just says a lot about
where she's headed in season five on to
number seven Peter asked Malia to kill
Peter is gunning for a dad of the year
first he asked her to kill then he
knocks her out cold across the room I am
sure she's not going to have any
lingering daddy issues whatsoever
not at all should be totally fine I
really do feel like with the half season
thing they had going on they just didn't
have enough time to explore Malia I feel
like there's so much unexplored
territory there they hinted from episode
to episode that she was slowly getting
used to being a human but then you have
like the deer moments where you see that
coyote brain poking through I'm really
interested to see next season how long
they spend on Malia getting used to
things or if she's gonna still be
confused by math Plus does anyone feel
like coyote brain would be a good
nickname for the other pack members to
give her like whenever she spaces out
they can just call her coyote brain and
it is super illegal to upload video
clips of TV shows but I really want a
montage of Malia just reacting to things
it would be all her quizzical faces just
her making faces of things and it would
be titled Malia doesn't understand her
bonding so intensely with stiles makes a
lot more sense now with all the crap
that Peter put her through this season
she'll probably end up doubling down on
family time with the pack like that's
gonna be her family on to number six we
still have no idea what perishes the WTF
here was the non reveal like they did
not reveal what he was I was kind of
looking forward to that I guess they
just didn't want to spend the money on a
full-on CG sequence they didn't want to
blow the budget or they're just saving a
lot for season 5 Parrish is like one of
those in-between characters where he
still has like one foot in the sheriff's
office in the normal world and one foot
in the pack
I think Stiles dad is always gonna be
his anchor to the real world and Parrish
is just gonna start floating slowly into
the world of the pack through that
bestiary book that was probably one of
the best teasers for season 5 just the
bestiary book onto number 5 Chris let's
Kate go
remember how I totally said that none of
the beautiful people would die I didn't
expect to be quite so right I kind of
made that comment as a joke but it
turned out to be true I felt like there
were two big takeaways from this final
scene of theirs first Kate is a little
bit nutters but like Peter she's like
the Peter of the Argent family she wants
to restore their honor and their power
Chris is like the Derek he'll never be
able to kill his sibling no matter how
terrible he or she gets so add to that
we have this new desert wolf wrinkle
does anybody feel like it could be Kate
Kate could be the desert wolf before I
thought about Kate I totally assumed it
was gonna be a new character we hadn't
seen yet and I'm still kind of hoping
that I feel like Peter and Kate would
have been way too high on the
selves to ever hook up and have a baby
if you ever watched the TV cartoon Young
Justice they actually did that thing
where Artemus was basically the daughter
of two criminals for all intents and
purposes so that could be where they're
trying to go with Malia's character but
on to number four Kiera learns to heal
herself couple of totally awesome care
moments in the finale the healing factor
was another one of those big things that
they didn't get too mechanical with like
they didn't really explain it in great
detail Jeff Davis though said during
wolf watch that when they were writing
Kiera this season they had to pick which
bits of the kitsune myth they wanted to
give to her like mythological casue
neighs had all kinds of power so they
didn't want to give her everything and
they picked healing just because it tied
it back to the pack she's taking on more
wolf-like qualities even if she's never
gonna be a wolf groups of people that
are really close will eventually start
to absorb each other's personality
traits so of course Kiera is gonna start
healing herself like the wolf's did
anyone else feel like Kira's mom was
giving her some tough love like she was
saying figure it out on your own just
tough it out just a flesh wound
here's mom's hundreds of years old which
the show hasn't really mentioned since
3b so I feel like it's authentic for her
to be so detached like she's literally
seeing everything a person can do
nothing surprises her unless that
something is a demon Stiles breaking her
last foxtail in number three another
Cara moment Kira gets her first fox tail
this is a really awesome win for her I
feel like everybody in the episode got
to win an award for making it through
another big challenge obviously Kira's
being that first foxtail so as she
continues to get more powerful and
overcome more obstacles so just get
those other eight tails I think nine
mythologically is the most they can have
I'd really like to see some bonus
content from MTV like either webisodes
or something like that where Kira's
mother tells her the stories of how she
got heard nine tails they're all gone
right now but Kira almost had to die and
evolve to get that first one so imagine
what she's gonna have to do to get the
other eight it also kind of reminds you
what a badass her mom is but number two
Peter confirms he was behind it all not
really surprised because he explained
everything during episode 11 and as
expected he totally went down hard
they said they specifically made en
bones wolf makeup to look like Duke
aliens just a callback to season 3 a and
Scott's struggle to become a true alpha
and I just love that they let Peter be
like this grand Shakespeare Theater
villain again it was fun to see him play
normal the first few episodes too but I
feel like he and Derek have this Loki
Thor relationship that will be really
interesting to see in season 5 or maybe
I should say Hannibal Lecter Clarice
Starling and Clarice Starling will be
played by Malia I really do feel like in
season 5 we're gonna see a lot of people
going to visit Peter mostly Malia going
to learn more about the desert wolf
because of the search for her the hunt
for the desert wolf Peter still has
something that the pack needs or I mean
Malia needs and by default the pack
needs it so he is not going away anytime
soon
and the VALIC Peter ship is gonna be
strong next year real big question
though Peter and violet stuck together
who is the wife and who is the husband I
mean I think we all feel like Peters
gonna be the wife it's a nice way to
laugh about him given all the terrible
he pulled this year and my number
one WTF moment Derek evolves into the
black wolf so Jeff Davis explained they
knew that this was where Derek would end
up before they ever started writing
season 4 because Derek's journey isn't
about being that alpha they had to
evolve his character in some other way
so for all intents and purposes he is
essentially just like the most perfect
form of wolf that you could become they
explained that being able to shift
completely into wolf form is something
only a true master can pull off so he's
like super Zen obi-wan Kenobi wolf now I
mean he's always kind of been the
obi-wan Kenobi character now they just
kind of took it a step further I did
predict that he would get his powers
back but I was totally surprised by the
way they explained it and as cool as
Derek during the Sheriff's Department
would have been clearly they have
something else planned for him next year
but now it's your turn let me know in
the comments were you happy with what
they did with Derek's character and do
you think the cape is the desert wolf or
is it some other new character why do
you think about that here's a few
general thoughts on season 4 as a whole
so some of my favorite moments from the
season were obviously Derek evolving
Scott showing his true off the form he
actually looked pretty freaky Kira
joining a little cross team hopefully
we'll actually see some real across next
season
Liam joining the pack was a breath of
fresh air Malayan Stiles definitely my
favorite ship and Malia just in general
was play my new favorite pack member
technically she wasn't a new character
though I'll say that Parrish is my most
anticipated season
five new pack member and right now my
best theory for him is Phoenix I'm a
little disappointed there's no 4b but
really the story will just pick up in
the same place that would have had
things been different so I don't think
we're missing any potential stories
there are a lot of rumors season 5 might
be their last but I think it's a little
too soon to tell so if I give the finale
a solid b-plus it had a nice conclusion
to the big benefactor arc as well as all
the character arts - like I really
enjoyed the way they evolved the
characters through the course of the
season Derek was the only one to say it
out loud but all the characters did
evolve Malia is evolving into a real
girl
Pinocchio style Scott into a true alpha
Lydia to a fully actualized Banshee
Parrish into a Phoenix I'm just gonna
keep saying Phoenix until I think of
something better if there's anything I
felt like the show could have done
better it wouldn't just be explaining
some of the more magical aspects a
little bit better
I just geeked out on stuff like that I
mean that's just me personally if any of
you guys watch Legend of Korra that's a
show that does a really good job of
explaining itself in great detail part
of the reason I make videos is to learn
new things so I'm really looking forward
to them exploring the bestiary if any of
you are Supernatural fans that's another
show that takes its literature really
seriously ala men of letters but overall
rate into a much more human season I
really like this season more than
three-beat just because they let the
cast act more like teenagers unless like
demon hunters it's a lot easier for me
to relate my own experience to them
whatever they're facing family problems
girlfriend problems high school problems
math problems so like I said I will be
posting my season 5 predictions tomorrow
be sure to subscribe to get that video
now here are some recommendations for
shows because Teen Wolf is going away
content I'll be doing videos for all
these things the new Monday night shows
are gonna be Gotham on Fox that starts
at the end of this month and Star Wars
rebels that doesn't start till October
but I will be doing bonus videos
starting next week then the flash with
Grant Gustin
you guys are really gonna like that that
starts Tuesdays in about 4 weeks on the
CW
then supernatural and agents of shield
season 2 all awesome shows shield is on
ABC arrow is gonna be my Wednesday show
that's also coming in about 4 weeks
they're basically doing Justice League
on TV and it's super badass Fridays are
gonna be Constantine the other DC Comics
TV show that's also coming in October
I will be posting a video this week that
will explain what my fall schedule is
going to be like when I'm going to be
posting videos and what they're gonna be
for but feel free to leave me
suggestions for any shows that you
really enjoyed that I'm not doing yet
right now click here to get last week's
Teen Wolf and click here to start
getting ready for arrow season 3 thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tomorrow
high fives